esta batalla por la ciudad de bakmuth en
el corazón del Don vas ha pasado a
convertirse tal vez en la batalla más
Sangrienta y dolorosa para Ucrania desde
el comienzo de esta invasión el 24 de
febrero del año pasado según las fuerzas
ucranianas ellos siguen resistiendo en
la ciudad y aseguraban esta mañana que
las últimas 24 horas han muerto
221 integrantes de las fuerzas rusas que
no solamente incluyen a estos
paramilitares sino a hombres
extremadamente entrenados del ejército
ruso también hablaban de 300 heridos
mientras que del lado de Moscú hablan
que 211 hombres de Ucrania murieron ayer
en todo el frente del donbas también se
argumenta que en las últimas horas los
rusos tienen el control del lado este de
la ciudad esto quiere decir que están al
otro lado del río backmuta tienen el
total control a pesar de que los
ucranianos no lo confirman y ellos dicen
que tienen algunas posiciones en ese
lado del río es importante porque esté
cru este río se encuentra ya el centro
de backmund donde también se han visto
en algunos vídeos presencia de soldados
rusos sin embargo el instituto de
estudios de la guerra que monitorea
especialmente esta batalla de backbood
dice que será más difícil para los rusos
porque allí están posicionados los
ucranianos que pueden defender ya con
batallas de hombre a hombre la defensa
de esta parte de la ciudad que sigue
siendo defendida por las autoridades
ucranianas esta defensa de la ciudad
dicen que si no es aquí luego tendría
que hacerse en otro lugar del Don vas y
prefieren hacerlo en este momento donde
tienen concentradas estas fuerzas
ucranianas pero también aseguran que
esta batalla se está concentrando y se
están acaparando todas estas fuerzas
aquí para dar tiempo a prepararse a
recibir esas armas que les van a dar sus
aliados occidentales y especialmente la
munición para preparar esa
contraofensiva que ellos están esperando
a comienzos de la primavera a finales de
abril o comienzos de mayo que es el gran
objetivo de Ucrania en este momento